こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです！
皆さん子供のころ何して遊んでましたか？
僕子供のころすごい割合のいい小学生でした。
外で遊ぶのが５０％
中で遊ぶのがちゃんと５０％でして
なんか、、文武両道できてましたね
幼少期のころ、僕を作り出すものがあったんですね
ひとつ
それがこちら！
ニューブロック！
これで遊んだことある人いますか？
僕もうこれでずっと遊んでて、
もう多分皆さん引きますよ
もう引くぐらいこれで遊んでて、
もうなんかこれさえあれば
何でも作れるんじゃねーかぐらい思ってて
こういう感じでいろいろブロックが入っているんですけども
これのね、なんか適応力がすごすぎて、
今なんか作れって言われたらすぐ作れますよ
今ぱっと思いついたんですけども、
これでもう剣作れますからね
ほら
完全に剣です
この剣をかっこよくしろって言われたら
僕はもうどこまででもできますからね☆
完全に
ジャッジメント、セイバー！！
これもう完全に
ジャッジメントセイバーまで作ることができました
けっｇ＃＿！∀くぁｗせｄｒｆｔｇｙふじこｌｐ
ですね
僕もうこれに育てられたといっても過言ではないです
ニューブロックさえあれば何でもできると思ってたんで、
今回！なんと！
１！２！３！４！５！６！７！８！９！１０！１１！１２～～～！
バラバラバラバラ（ブロックが落ちる音）
・・・（沈黙
ぴりゅりゅ！
１２箱あって、1箱１８３パーツあります。
てことは、、
１８３×１２＝、、、２～～～～１９６
はい、ていうわけで２１９６個のブロックがあるんですけども、
大人になった俺の力を見せてやる（中二病風）
もう僕もいい年でもう２４ですよ？
この年になれば、もう（謎のジェスチャー）やばいよ？脳内。
脳内でくｍ☆！”＄＆’＄もう異常なことになってるんで
これだけのブロックがあればきっととんでもないのが作れると思うので
ちょっと今回これだ！もう夢！夢夢夢！
だっておいらん家これ二つしかなかったもん
二つでやっとかっと楽しんでたのにもう12個もあるから、
最高に楽しめると思います(｀・ω・´)
今日は俺のブロック技術を見せてやろうと思う
ぶじゅ！
まずイメージを決めんのが大事な～これ
な！なんでお前くっついてる！（怒）ぶしゃ～～
あ～きついな～ドラゴンだな！僕はドラゴン大好きなんだ！
作業中
あれぇ？
う～～う～～～～～う～～なんでぇ？なんでぇ！なんでなんでなんでぇ？
は！？
え！？
作業中
ガラガラガラ（ブロックの音）
あ！あ！あ！あ！あ！
まってぇ～もう限界かも、もう限界かも
これ以上おっきくすると倒れる！
作業中
ガシャ！
あ！あ！あ！あ！あ！あ！あ！あ！あ！あ！ふぁあああ！ふぁあああ！
作業中　　　　ええ、、もう駄目なの？（小声）
うげぇ！
やらかしたわこれ
あの・・これはミスであってですね・・なんだろちょっとわ！じゃ！
もうやめ
わああああぁぁぁ！あ！あ！あ！あ！あ！ああああぁぁぁ・・
もうこれミスで～～（泣
わざとじゃないんですよ～～・・（泣
キン！
・・・（沈黙
ぴぴ～～～～！！
ダムドロン（ry
です。
あのー…
しくったなー
ちょっとロボット系で細く作りすぎててこれ以上多分なにか積むとすぐ倒れるんですよ
こうやってつけるともう、すぐたおれます
ちょっと難しぃー！
どれだけ数があっても
結局バランス取らないと崩れることが今回分かったので
もうちょっとこうフレームを大きくしたら大きくなったのかなと思います
ちょっとまさきに見せてみよ！
がしゃ！（ドア音）まさき～～？
ちょっと来て～～
・・・（沈黙
（まさき）すごくね？
（はじめ）マジで言ってる？
ぺぺぺぺぺぺぺぺぺぺ～～～ぺぺぺぺ～ぺ～ぺぺぺぺ～～ぺ～ぺぺぺぺぺぺ～ぺ～ぺ～～～～ぺぺぺぺ！
(はじめ)いや、ほんとにすごいっておもってる？
(まさき)うん
(はじめ)これだよ？
(はじめ)まじ？(喜)
あ、タヒんだし